Trascrizione: Cristina Maria Leoni
Revisore: Giorgia Borsellino
Qualcuno di voi conosce
il significato di questo gesto?
Questo è il gesto che viene utilizzato
da noi sub durante un’immersione,
per avvisare gli altri
che è ora di tornare alla barca.
Il motivo per cui dobbiamo utilizzare
un linguaggio dei segni è semplice:
l’uomo sott’acqua è muto.
Eppure il mondo sottomarino
è tutt’altro che silenzioso.
Questa sono io alla mia prima
immersione in Liguria.
Mi ricordo che mi trovavo
a 20 metri di profondità,
quando improvvisamente
sentii un rumore fortissimo
che mi spaventò.
Iniziai allora a guardarmi attorno
per cercare la fonte del rumore,
ma non vidi nulla.
Guardai in su allora,
aspettandomi di vedere la scia
di una barca passata sopra di me.
Ma la superficie dell’acqua era liscia
e senza nessuna increspatura.
Realizzai quindi quello che gli istruttori
mi avevano detto in classe.
Il suono, sott’acqua, viaggia molto
più velocemente che nell’aria.
E quindi, probabilmente,
la barca che era passata
si trovava a centinaia di metri da me.
Ma io l'avevo sentita così vicina.
Nel mio viaggio di ritorno
verso la costa iniziai a riflettere,
a come gli animali percepivano
lo stesso suono che mi aveva spaventata.
Si erano ormai abituati?
Avevano cambiato le loro abitudini
a causa di questo suono?
Arrivata a casa la mia ricerca proseguì
e mi imbattei nel termine
“antropogenic noise pollution”
che sembra complesso,
ma in realtà è molto semplice.
Si tratta di tutti i suoni
prodotti dall’uomo,
che hanno, in qualche modo, un’influenza
sull’ambiente e le specie che lo abitano.
Questi sono due sonogrammi.
Un sonogramma è un grafico
che mostra l’intensità e la frequenza
di un suono nel tempo.
In particolare, il sonogramma di sinistra
è quello di una balenottera comune,
che nuota indisturbata.
Quello di destra è il sonogamma della
stessa balenottera comune,
con in sottofondo
il rumore del traffico marittimo.
È impossibile non vedere
quanto questo secondo suono
sovrasti quasi completamente il primo.
Le balene sono animali che comunicano,
si spostano e si accoppiano
grazie al suono,
producendo i cosiddetti canti,
che tutti noi conosciamo bene.
Il traffico marittimo, quindi,
è una delle principali cause
dell’estinzione delle balene,
insieme alla caccia e
ai cambiamenti climatici.
Ma perché concentrarsi
sulle balene, direte voi.
L’estinzione delle balene,
non solo provocherebbe la perdita
di un animale socievole, maestoso,
e che purtroppo
non conosciamo ancora bene.
Le balene sono anche
delle ottime alleate dell’uomo
nella lotta ai cambiamenti climatici,
perché compiono un processo
chiamato Whale Pump.
Le balene sono gli unici animali marini
a produrre delle feci liquide,
che quindi galleggiano in superficie,
portando con sé tutti i nutrienti.
In superficie si trova il fitoplancton,
che si nutre del ferro
contenuto nelle feci,
e riesce così a prosperare,
a compiere la fotosintesi clorofilliana,
consumare CO2 e produrre ossigeno.
Se pensate anche solo
alla stazza di una balena
non sarà difficile capire quanti nutrienti
può dare al fitoplancton,
che da solo è responsabile del 50%
dell’ossigeno che abbiamo nell’atmosfera.
Una ricerca australiana
afferma che, in un anno, una balena
consuma 15.000 chili di CO2.
Per darvi un’idea, un albero all’anno
ne consuma 30 di chili.
Il valore ecologico, quindi, di una balena
è uguale a quello di 555 alberi.
La ricerca del Fondo Monetario
Internazionale afferma che
se il numero delle balene passasse
da quello attuale, di un milione e tre,
a quello di quattro o cinque milioni,
questo provocherebbe un fortissimo impatto
sulla produttività del fitoplancton.
Se anche solo questa produttività
aumentasse dell′1%,
equivarrebbe all’improvvisa comparsa
di due miliardi di alberi,
maturi e pronti a produrre ossigeno.
È incredibile.
Mentre l’uomo cerca
soluzioni complesse e spesso costose
per risolvere i problemi dei
cambiamenti climatici,
la natura ne ha già una, semplice,
economica e collaudata da anni:
le balene.
Questa è la mappa della parte nord
occidentale del Mar Mediterraneo.
È una zona dove il traffico
marittimo è molto intenso,
e sono poche le aree
non attraversate da rotte navali.
Proprio in questa parte del Mediterraneo,
ogni anno, migliaia di esemplari
di balenottera comune
migrano dallo Stretto
di Sicilia alle coste della Liguria.
È inevitabile che questa migrazione non
sia influenzata, in qualche modo,
dai rumori del traffico marittimo,
che spesso portano le balene
a collisioni o spiaggiamenti.
Come designer ho provato a dare una
soluzione a questo problema.
Il risultato è un’autostrada silenziosa,
che si vada ad innestare nei punti in cui
il tragitto delle balene
si sovrappone a quello delle rotte navali,
garantendo alle balene
una migrazione sicura e tranquilla.
Il corridoio silenzioso sottomarino
è formato da moduli, ovvero delle corde,
sulle quali vengono impilati
degli elementi fonoassorbenti.
I moduli poi, affiancati l’uno all’altro,
formano le pareti
del corridoio sottomarino
e, se da un lato non permettono
al suono delle navi di passare,
dall’altro, lasciano liberi di entrare
e di uscire le balene
e gli altri animali marini.
Se una balena, infatti, dovesse andarsi
a scontrare contro le pareti del corridoio
le corde semplicemente si piegherebbero,
lasciandola passare senza arrecare danni.
Il concetto base, infatti, di questo
progetto è stato, sin dall’inizio,
quello di guidare l’animale
nella migrazione, senza mai intrappolarlo.
Per non creare un ambiente artificiale,
e quindi totalmente estraneo all’animale,
è stato necessario studiare elementi
che esistono già nel mondo sottomarino.
Uno tra questi è l’alga.
In particolare, l’alga corallina,
che si trova sulla barriera corallina,
è stata presa di ispirazione per la forma
degli elementi fonoassorbenti.
L’alga kelp, invece, è stata studiata
per il suo principio di galleggiamento.
Le corde, infatti,
sono ancorate al fondale,
e arrivano fino alla
superficie dell’acqua.
Per permettere loro
di scoprire questa lunghezza,
è stato necessario intervallare
dei piccoli galleggianti,
proprio come avviene nelle alghe kelp.
La parte più tecnica del progetto è stata
lo studio di un materiale fonoassorbente
in grado di bloccare
le frequenze emesse dalle navi
e lasciar passare
quelle emesse dalle balene.
In modo da permettere loro
di continuare a comunicare,
nonostante il corridoio.
La ricerca sui materiali fonoassorbenti
sott'acqua non è ancora avanzata.
Inoltre, le frequenze da bloccare
erano molto basse,
il che ha reso tutto
ancora più complicato.
Nonostante ciò, è stato possibile
individuare un materiale che,
grazie a dei piatti in metallo inseriti
in una struttura a disco elastica,
riesce a bloccare
le basse frequenze sott’acqua.
Questo progetto quindi è il frutto di una
collaborazione tra tre materie:
il design, per la parte di
progettazione spaziale,
l’ingegneria, per lo studio
dell’elemento fonoassorbente,
ed infine la biologia, per la
ricerca sui movimenti degli animali.
Questa idea, è il primo passo
di un lungo percorso
che inizia nell’oggi
e si proietta nel domani.
È un esempio di Speculative Design.
Una materia che ha lo scopo
di cercare questioni da discutere
e di provare a creare
possibili narrazioni future,
per aiutarci ad interrogarci sulle
implicazioni sul nostro presente.
La ricerca, infatti, sui
movimenti delle balene
non dà ancora risultati attendibili.
Inoltre, il materiale fonoassorbente
ha ancora bisogno di test e collaudi.
Nonostante ciò, ho sentito il bisogno
di provare a dare una mia visione futura
per provare a limitare il problema
dell’estinzione delle balene.
All’inizio di questo progetto,
la domanda che mi sono posta è stata:
come designer, cosa posso fare
per creare un futuro migliore?
Con quest’idea spero non solo
di aver dato il mio contributo,
ma anche di aver dato a voi
che state ascoltando
la consapevolezza che, qualsiasi sia
la vostra professione o passione,
potete tutti dare il vostro contributo
e aggiungere un piccolo e originale pezzo
al grande puzzle multidisciplinare
per creare un futuro migliore
e, possibilmente, pieno di balene.
Grazie.